I also want to know if you've been
paying attention to something else
that's been circulating around the
internet and it has a little something
to do with the adaptation of the last of
us there are a lot of people out there
even before we signed on to this called
people the chat were like she needs to
play Ellie in The Last of Us
have you seen that and are you
interested
um well this is the first time I listen
I am a huge fan of the game and I don't
know if a lot of people know that but
I'm saying it now I am a huge fan of
that video game I think it is a
beautiful story it's it's it's it's a
it's a just a wonderful narrative and I
fell in love with that game when it came
out and I played it with my dad and we
just had the best time I'm not very good
at it I'm not my aim is really bad and I
but I'm I'm working on working on
getting better at playing but I love
that I love the Last of Us I think it's
an incredible story and III obviously
have been seeing the internet and I've
obviously been seeing a lot a lot of
that I've Neil druckmann I did I worked
with him on uncharted 4 yes I think he's
at one of the smartest guys I've ever
met and one of the sweetest and I would
I I'm not I'm not shutting it down you
know I'm not shooting it down I would I
would absolutely love to do that but I
don't know I don't know where it's at
yeah but I love the Last of Us so as a
fan of the game let's say you were the
one able to fan cast Joel who would you
pick
oh my god there's so many I mean
obviously I've seen the I've seen
there's so many people that would be so
great for that role I mean I have seen
the the fan casts of the Hugh Jackman as
Joel I I like that one and I also know
Hugh and I've worked with you and I
think he's the nicest guy in the world
so I think he should be in everything